run away feed us right yes levi we're
gonna switch it up yeah why can't you be
out here you know just move around these
are very casual these run in no
particular order anybody said i was not
involved at all
hey conor o'brien here with uh some of
the writers uh in no particular order
for another edition of behind the
nonsense where we uh talk a little bit
about what went into making some really
stupid comedy jose walk us through the
setup to this cause people forget
current events people move on tell us
well it was around i think around 2013
or so um
kim kardashian was pregnant with her
first child and um there was of course a
lot of paparazzi pursuing her and so i
came up with the idea that the paparazzi
uh went to one of her ultrasounds uh
just just to you know get get footage
and something really bizarre happened
and that's where we came up with this
that's where we came up with the sketch
and uh let's roll it and then we can
discuss
whether this should ever have been made
take a look
let's go now live to kim kardashian's
exam room if you would
and there's the doctor he's examining
kim kardashian on the table and there is
the baby baby looks fine and healthy the
baby is just wait a minute realizing now
that she's kim kardashian and kanye
west's child
not happy about that and making a break
for it
the baby is making a girlfriend
the baby wants no part of this
oh no baby
baby is getting away with the placenta
and making a break for it in the
hospital
okay they've got security and the
doctors are after the baby
the baby will not be taken no baby
getting
down the staircase
the baby does not oh no penny
using the placenta to get into a police
car
has hot wired the police car
and is making a break for it this is big
news kanye and kim's baby
moving down the highway that looks to be
the 405 maybe the 101 that is an
incredible story
incredible what's going on you're
kidding i'm told that he's abandoned the
cop car he is now he's what i'm
pretending to listen he's hijacked
shut up
what's that jeff
he's hijacked a motorcycle and he's
headed this way
that's insanity
[Applause]
[Music]
baby took that corner a little fast but
now
baby's fine and the placenta safely in a
side car
and there he goes
help the baby
where do you think he got the little
goggles i don't know
all right
as much fun as you might imagine
it would be to do a a piece like that
you know live and be the person
sort of the ring master for that it is
even more fun than you can imagine
saying oh my god the baby's on the run
and hearing
i mean first of all i love a good sight
gag and
that baby running rappelling down its
own umbilical cord
and then using the placenta as the
boomerang to get up into
into a cop car
there's so many i mean
it's so insane but just delightful
and it really is sort of mind-expanding
because you think about a a baby
becoming self-aware and realizing its
parents or celebrities exactly not
wanting to be part of it and having the
presence of mind to start hot wiring
cars
and motorcycles
and then there was another part right
there was two more of we just tracked
the fetus as it was going across the
country and
we shoot it running across the u.s map
of course you know as it's hiding from
people but it ends happily because the
last one part three
it dives back into kim kardashian oh my
god
and the baby
returns
i'm sorry i'm thinking now like my dad
like a scientist
i was filling in for sweeney that
particular day you saw on the feed they
were rehearsing the baby driving the
motorcycle and you just said i want to
do that
you just wiped everything off it was
scheduled for this
show yeah it looked like too much fun
and it was like a toy you see that you
say i want to play with that now i don't
want to do anything else i want that
right now i want to eat the cake now i
don't want my vegetables i don't want
our pithy take on
the the new administration i want to do
that historically we used to do things
on late night where we would do traffic
reports or cover things we're little
models i always like anything that
involves a little toy a puppet a model
things on the run things on the lam and
jose is a comic book artist and almost
thinks in comic book panels yes this is
a whole storyboard for that
this guy's storyboards his breakfast
wow i can hear the clicks
he's a very good artist and he draws
these and we'll be shooting something
that i think is just like yeah we'll put
a camera here we'll shoot gallagher with
the mallet and then he'll hit the melon
and it'll squash and he's got it all
figured out and these beautiful uh
storyboards are drawn that's the first
time i've ever seen that and it's like
that type of like just the the stupidity
of that as a fan that that made me go
like conan is the best like the type of
thing that can be done on this show that
you don't see on any other show and it's
just pure absurd i mean it doesn't
apologize for itself you already got the
job skills
but no there is uh it's the never ending
quest is to try and or or my belief
system i have is that things can be
really smart and really stupid at the
exact same time and i can't explain why
that's true there's so many intelligent
little things happening in that piece
that are just good sight gags in the way
it's shot in the way it's presented and
the whole concept
and it's also as skyler says really
stupid
and they can co-exist at the same time i
don't know why that is that's one of the
mysteries of this business but
i feel like if nothing else our show is
the pursuit of what's smart and stupid
at the same time i think and also it's
all in-house like you talked to bill
toll and props like they'll tell i need
a baby with a side placenta i need a
yeah
what size what size how big should the
percentage oh that's the other thing too
is you
yeah
how many weeks
what
[Laughter]
this time fake yeah all right we've
learned that i'll get one of each
that's the crazy thing too is people are
behind the scenes completely straight
face like okay we've got uh the the
fetus on the motorcycle and the placenta
uh you wanted it in the sidecar and
we've got goggles on the baby how could
anyone talk about that
with a straight face and people say like
right okay no we had a little trouble
getting him to climb up into the police
car but then we figured out a way for
him to work the shifter when people are
arguing and yelling about no
no the placenta keeps falling out of the
siding
and someone else would be like i'm
trying we put the placenta in but when
the baby when the fetus takes a sharp
turn the placenta won't get it right
and you realize you're having adults are
having an argument about the stupidest
thing in the world look if we can't get
this to work we're going to have to do
diarrhea cannon today
it would have been really easy for the
baby to run out
with with no umbilical cord or placenta
but leaving it attached
and using it was the best joke
in the entire piece and that's an
important comedy rule always always
also it's a valuable source of oxygen
for the fetus otherwise we'd get all
these calls like the fetus couldn't do
that without them right yeah so yeah
jose is a midwife
yeah it's a biologically accurate sketch
yeah very good smash that like button
subscribe